investigators in Florida are trying to
determine how a car rolled off a ferry
into a channel about 50 feet deep
killing both women inside the car was
apparently at the front of the ferry
which was transporting vehicles and
passengers from Fisher Island to Miami
Beach some two miles away Manuel
Bojorquez is in Miami Beach with more on
this story
Manuel I know this is a very popular
route what do they think happen
well good morning it is the Association
which runs the line says it operates
multiple ferries every day now Fisher
Island right over there is billed as one
of the wealthiest communities in the
country with the only ways on or off by
boat or ferry and people who live there
say they have never heard of anything
like this happening before the first
distress calls came in just after 5:00
p.m. Tuesday a Mercedes Benz that was
being driven by 63 year old Emma Afra
with 75 year old Viviane Brahms as her
passenger had somehow rolled off the
ferry dive crews searched the waters
overnight eventually finding the two
deceased women inside the car which was
brought back on shore and towed away
it's still very early in the
investigative process our teams here
from sector Miami alongside Miami Dade
County Police have communicated with the
crew and with passengers and are just
beginning to put those pieces together
the Fisher Island community association
which runs the ferry issued a statement
saying the entire community mourns their
loss and our hearts and prayers go out
to their families and loved ones
this gentleman's I guess putting
something in front of the tire a
producer with Inside Edition took the 7
minute trip on the same ferry line
chalks were put in front of his wheels
to keep the car from rolling they're
reportedly not required by law but the
Coast Guard tells the Miami Herald the
crew is believed to have used them to
secure the Mercedes on Tuesday there was
only what appears to be a thin barrier
of netting between the cars and the
water nobody told me anything about
putting my car in park or turning the
car off Fisher Island is an exclusive
community with a population of about 800
families where the average home costs
more than two million dollars
I've been living
for 23 years and that you know this has
never happened
sources familiar with the investigation
told the Miami Herald Afra may have
forgotten to put the car in park and
then accidentally hit the gas pedal they
also report the women were found in an
apparent embrace in the backseat Anthony
very said Manuel thank you